let's get a try and get it working
[Music]
yes
that's like fonzie
that's exactly what i thought and
there's a reference that would be lost
on most of the audience oh we've got two
stations fantastic
so the business end is actually up here
all this is doing is amplifying stuff
we've got a station down there boys
london's calling oh how perfect is that
so this is a london station it's called
absolute
and this is all coming out of a penny
tiny wire and a penny and our penny is
acting as a diode rectifying the signal
and we are picking up a station called
absolute radio all the way from london
on a piece of wire hung out of my office
which is acting as an antenna
and actually if we didn't have this and
we had a pair of headphones this thing
would work with no power source phil i
thought you're like a high-powered
physicist what are you doing messing
around with this so it all goes back
about um how many years would it be 41
years 41 years to this book this book
was actually published in 1972
and this is where for me physics started
my uncle benny was a radio amateur
really interested in shortwave radio and
listening to shortwave radium building
antennas getting better signals he and i
when i was about 10
use this book to build something which
is called a crystal radio so we've got a
coil which is an inductor we've got a
capacitor which we can tune so we can
change the capacitance a diode which is
something called a rectifier which means
it only lets current flow one way and a
pair of headphones or indeed i used an
earpiece exactly like this it's what's
called a piezoelectric or a crystal
earpiece is this the actual book or this
is a this is i really wish i had the
actual book um i suspect if i had the
actual book it wouldn't quite be in this
good equality there's a whole new series
of ladybird books by the way that some
of you might have seen which are pretty
good the zombie
apocalypse mindfulness
and best of all the student lisa finds
her revision timetable very tiring that
is because it starts at 1am when she can
be sure daytime television has
definitely finished there are spoof of
these books i learned a lot there was
this one and this one and a whole host
of other ones basically you use a plank
of wood and we weren't even as technical
as putting screws in it what you use
instead are
what i would call thumbtacks or drawing
pins and we just press those into the
board and we wedge the component leads
underneath so here right we have our
coil coil here capacitor which is this
thing i went down to our ever friendly
electronics workshop and said i'd like
an old style vane capacitor because i
want to recreate this and they went here
you go phil and then i hunted through a
few of these to find one with the good
capacitance and one that was actually
working what they used to do and for
example these were also known known as
crystal radios but they were also known
as foxhole radios and prisoners of war
used to build them in the in the second
world war and they couldn't get their
hands on something like this so what the
other thing you can do instead of
changing the capacitance and having a
capacitance variable you can change the
inductance and the way you do that is
you have different what are called taps
on the coil so instead of connecting the
diode right at the end you might connect
it here or here or here or here and that
allows you to change the frequency that
you're detecting so when i initially
built this all those years ago we used
something which is called a silicon
diode the important thing with this is
it only allows current to flow one way
and so instead of it sloshing back and
forth like this it's just allowing it to
flow in one direction that's really
really important in terms of being able
to detect the signal and to pull out the
signal to extract the signal
um the music the sound the voice from
what's called the carrier wave which is
the radio wave itself the radio wave
itself
is a combination of what's called a
carrier wave which is very high
frequency maybe a million times going
back and forth maybe a million times a
second electric field flipping back and
forth at a megahertz and of course the
audio signal is much much lower than
that it's at tens of kilohertz and so
this along with the other elements in
the circuit pulls out the audio the
music the talk whatever from from the
overall radio wave phil when you're a
boy you said that you used you used one
of them yeah what have you done today so
what i've done today this is amazing i
can't believe this actually works so
with a penny in the uk at least it's
different in the us i've done my wiki
homework on this in the uk where you
have a stainless steel and it's coated
with copper but of course that copper
oxidizes and this is a fairly badly
oxidized you can see even little patches
of green stuff on this penny if you look
carefully and the wonderful thing is
just like silicon copper oxide is
something called a semiconductor and so
with this type of of diode what happens
is you get two different types of
silicon one which is doped what's called
n-type and another which is called dope
p-type the doping changes the
connectivity and you sandwich those
together and the
when those two materials interact and
mix to a certain extent what happens is
that you get a barrier for electrons to
flow in one direction and not a barrier
in the other direction now wonderfully
you can also do the same thing with a
metal on semiconductor contact and it's
called a schottky diode this is about
the most rudimentary form of a schottky
diode one can imagine it's called a
cat's whisker in that we've got a wire
touching very very gently because we
want to touch the oxide we don't want to
dig through to hit the copper or the
steel underneath because then we'll
short everything out so we want to have
a weak contact so we've got this thing
in this wire and it's acting almost like
a spring so it's so delicate right it's
gone completely now so we've got to try
and recover it this might involve quite
a lot of swearing
no
and it goes again and so this is what
they used to do can you imagine being in
the sort of trenches in your prison
award just moving this thing around or
so frustrated you want to have some sort
of outside contact
what's happening when you hit the table
so this contact here is moving ever ever
so slightly and so what i want to do is
just jog it so it finds a nice spot on
the penny where we got a good
come on you pig
[Music]
okay so that's not great so it depends
very much on where you are in the penny
we can tune it a little bit
not bad this is on a penny
on a penny when i first did this i think
i got more excited than when i did it as
a 10 year old obviously there was a
recent nobel prize and i was just
reading this blog which is in the dark
by guy called peter cole but he's
talking about the um princeton press
conference for jim peoples i'm sure
you've done something on jim peebles
recently brady and there's this
wonderful quote my from peebles my
advice is not to aim
my advice is not to aim for prizes and
awards they will come or they won't
don't judge your career by the number by
the counter prizes we're in this for the
joy of research the fascination the love
of science that is the reward really and
honestly when this thing worked last
night when i tried it for the first time
i was jumping around the room
um and i'm now quite a bit older than i
was when i first made it but still it
was still the same punching the air
moment phil we've done videos before
about your real research and one thing
we always talk about is that tip of your
microscope and how sensitive it is
it reminds me exactly but even better
than that brady even better i thought oh
thank you for that wonderful
unplanned segue this is one of the
silicon samples
from our stm this is a sample one well
but there are two samples there both of
which we've imaged with atomic
resolution and what i'm going to do is
take this and let's see if we can use
one of these silicon samples it should
be easier than a penny
to actually detect the signal because
we've got a semiconductor and we've got
a metal so okay we'll take that out i
probably will never get it working again
piece of silicon this is going to
replace the
penny okay so i just have to adjust it
enough pressure so it sits under there
but not so much that it cracks
just bear with me this is always fiddly
yes
got it
yes that's what we'd expect it's a
better semiconductor than a crappy old
penny so we should expect a better
signal physics works
so we're tuning our circuit there's our
signal how's it going i think there's
another one back here
notice no attention paid to screening
this is about as heath robinson as it
gets so that's our signal that's our
ground and i've just coupled them
together i wanted it to be as close as
possible to what happened
years ago
[Music]
come on radio plays a song of course you
could possibly me
all right just don't breathe really it's
new zealand and right now it's absolute
radio dot co dot uk thank you absolute
radio for being on exactly the right
frequency of course because what you can
do is you can work out what frequency
you're detecting from the inductance
here and the capacitance here
but um i wish i'd planned it that much
you can see from the really
higgledy-piggledy wiring i didn't put a
lot of effort into this
and it worked
green day hey what's up
it's a rock radio as well i was very
happy
[Music]
so make the best of this
of your life
happy
yeah it's good isn't it yeah it's really
good
we didn't stop here you can hear even
more from phil particularly on the topic
of resonant frequency notice i'm not
driving it the amplitude stays the same
all i'm changing is the frequency this
is really important there are links on
screen and in the video description
and to see more videos including plenty
more from phil check out everything on
our channel 60 symbols or we can do what
we're doing here and we can listen to it